spatial Computing is the newest term
that you'll hear be tossed around and
until you actually experience the Apple
Vision Pro in real life it might be hard
to grasp its ability to transport you
into another world while staying inside
of your comfy cozy Apple ecosystem is
what really sets this apart from other
headsets of course the price does as
well but this really is unlike anything
I've ever
[Music]
experienced the most impressive thing
about it though is way that it just
feels intuitive as soon as you put it on
the natural way you just look at
something and you make a pinching
gesture to select it and it just
freaking works like it truly feels like
you're witnessing a miracle now the tech
in this thing is what is really so
impressive just the cameras and the
sensors alone and the way that they're
able to duplicate such a real life
experience with the pass through video
now when you first get the headset the
setup process is super simple you have
the battery pack that you plug right
into the headset this should get you
about 2 to 2 and 1/2 hours of battery
life now for obvious reasons this is not
a MAG safe adapter you line up these two
dots and then you turn it and as soon as
they're aligned you'll notice that this
LED lights up and then as soon as that
led stops blinking it's time to put it
on now as soon as it's on your head
it'll do an auto adjustment to your eyes
and then you'll go through this series
of eye tracking tests by looking at
these different color dots in different
lighting conditions and then pinching
each time you look at them to select and
the first time that you start this up
you are greeted by this old school
animated hello in your own environment
now this is one that they sent me just
to show you guys because I couldn't
actually capture it as I was doing the
setup but it's so wild like it looks
almost like real life when this just
pops up in your room the thing that I
have noticed though after wearing this
for the past week there is this slight
eye fatigue that you would naturally
feel when you're looking at a display
but it's kind of hard to explain because
it's like your brain knows that it's not
real but it looks so real but it kind of
still feels like you're looking at a
display but then your brain is saying oh
no I don't know it looks pretty real
we're a little confused now when you
walk around or you look at your phone
and things up close that's when you can
kind of tell because the phone is
brighter than it would look in real life
and really the best view when you're
using this headset is when you're kind
of looking at a wide view of your space
and it still is just so surprising when
I put this on and immediately I'm
greeted by the world around me and these
little app icons right in front of my
face now as for Content there is a new
app store that is dedicated just to
Vision Pro for all of the new apps it's
pretty awesome because you can still use
iPad and iOS apps that have chosen to be
available on Vision Pro which means on
day one you've got over a million apps
that you can use now obviously they
aren't going to be as enhanced to take
advantage of spatial Compu
but you can still open them up use them
and move them around your space now
making your persona is definitely
something that you want to do first this
will let you get a 3D map of your
likeness so you can use it to make
FaceTime calls and the front display can
use eyesight with a digital version of
your eyes and it's so wild because it's
so easy like you actually just use the
Vision Pro to capture your face by
holding it out in front of you and it'll
guide you through the steps you look
right you look left you look up down
smile without teeth smile with teeth
raise your eyebrows and then close your
eyes and that's it it will capture the
outfit that you're wearing so make sure
it's something that you'd want to be
seen in and also make sure if you're
wearing any jewelry like that your
necklace is straight because it will not
in fact straighten it for you as you can
see here so this is my Persona and it
did take me a few tries before I got one
that I liked the most difficult part was
because my hair kept slipping in front
of my face and then it would get stuck
and then blurred to the side so if you
have longer hair sometimes having a
little separation of your hair and the
face is the way to go now doing a
FaceTime in Vision Pro I will say is
probably one of the wildest experiences
now I had made a few calls to people who
didn't have Vision Pro and for them they
will just see your persona and then I'll
see them as you would normally now I
absolutely shocked my sister when I
first called her because she had no idea
what was going on and I don't even think
that some people would believe it even
if you told them oh um yeah this is just
my digital Persona that I scanned using
a headset and now it's using cameras and
various sensors to depict my subtle
facial movements okay you know super
casual what really sold it for me though
is when I did a call with my friends
Marquez and Brian and after a while I'm
say like after about 30 minutes of us
chatting it just started feeling normal
like At first we were all shocked
because it looked like us sounded like
us but it wasn't us when it's like the
attention to detail too like I know we
all make fun of Apple like oh when Apple
does something like then it's going to
be a thing but man they really made this
super impressive from just a teex
standpoint it's it's freaking incredible
yeah I want
more I wanted to do more things yeah I
mean this is day Zero negative right now
so we've got many many awesome things to
come and with the incredible spatial
sound on this it was really tricking my
brain into thinking they were actually
right there in the room with me in those
little boxes and the other cool detail
is how it really shows you in FaceTime
what you're looking at for example when
I was trying to show Brian a little hand
heart Marquez couldn't see it because I
was showing it to Brian who was over
here then when I mov my hand to the
other side so that Marquez could see it
I mean it was a kind of a mind-blowing
experience just to see this happen in
real time and us all kind of trying to
figure it out but again the thing was
these little personas took seconds to
make and they worked so well it's also
still in beta so obviously this is only
going to get better I was also really
excited about this that I've never
actually even seen before on Apple TV
there's a little section for 3D movies
and I cannot stress enough how much I
used to hate 3D movies like I would
never even want to see them in the
theater and even just using like the
regular 3D glasses was such a subpar
experience but finally I can say that
this has completely changed my thoughts
on 3D films I did watch part of the
force awakens and the Mario movie and it
was just it was Unreal the coolest part
is you can watch any of these in an
immersive environment or you can place
yourself in a theater and have your
choice of seat so you can watch
something from the floor the back or the
balcony you can take your pick like it's
whatever you want wherever you like to
sit in the theater you can have that
theater experience now the only problem
is I could not capture any content of me
watching that because it was all
copywritten and it wouldn't let me
record the screen when the movies were
playing so just trust me when I say it
was freaking awesome and get yourself to
an Apple store to test this out
immediately like there has been so many
little things that I've been loving
about Vision Pro and every time that
I've used it over the last week I was
more and more impressed with it every
single time I put it on this is really
just the beginning and I cannot wait to
see the amazing things that people
create for it the biggest downside
though for me was the weight it is heavy
like it's shockingly Heavy after it's on
your head for a while especially with
the solo Loop band which I have here it
doesn't really allow for any weight
distribution on the top of your head but
using the Dual Loop will give you some
added resistance that definitely helps
out a lot right now the longest time
I've been able to stay in it is for
about 45 minutes and then I need a
little break I would say if you are new
to VR and you've never worn any type of
headsets like this take your time don't
hop into this and think that you're
going to be sitting in here for like
several hours at a time on day one even
though that's the only thing that I
wanted to do I I think this is something
that you do need to ease yourself into
because it is an all new muscle that
you're forming with your eyes the way
that you have to look so deliberately
you don't normally do that and it's such
a weird feeling but I think the reason
that it's so weird is because you look
at something and then you can like you
can touch it and bring it towards you
it's just I don't know it's so crazy
like I've done a lot of VR experiences
in the past and I do like VR but I don't
really like the idea of wearing these
heavy headsets so the thing about this
is seeing
Apple's Vision apple apple Vision okay I
did that was an accident but seeing
their vision for the future of computing
like I get it I freaking get it and I
cannot wait for it because one example
that I cannot wait to try is editing on
an airplane with this now this is a demo
that I'm so excited to try out you can
take your laptop and you can basically
make a 4K display in your headset so
you're going to mirror your computer
into your head and be able to edit and
work and you can use your laptop to type
you can use the mouse so basically
wherever you are you can use this as a
display I mean it is definitely an
expensive display but this is a lot
smaller to pack than a massive 4K
display in your suitcase I have become
so accustomed to editing on my 14-in
MacBook so now editing inside of Vision
Pro off of my 14-in MacBook it kind of
makes me feel like I'm just at home with
my multiple monitors and even while I'm
mirroring my display I still have all of
this spatial Computing area that I can
place things like by text messages
there's so many opportunities with this
and I cannot wait to experience them all